-We're about to play
The Whisper Challenge.
-Whisper Challenge.
-Alright, now here's
how the game works,
one person puts
on these headphones
with loud music playing.
You played this game at home.
Then the other person
picks up a card,
reads the random phrase
on that card,
and the person wearing
the headphones
has to try and guess
what they just said.
Bryce, why don't you put
the headphones on first.
-Okay, here we go.
-Yep.
And I'll put the song on here.
-I have zero expectations of
this being successful at all.
-Yep. No.
Can. Can you hear me? Good.
Perfect. Okay. Ready?
-Okay. Yeah.
I hear music and nothing else.
-You're very loud.
-Yeah, it's very loud.
-Okay, good.
Okay.
Cinnamon bun.
-I sleep and baba-dah.
[ Laughter ]
-Cinnamon bun.
-Sleeping number.
-Cinnamon.
-Sleeping? Right, obviously.
It's not "sleeping."
-Cinn--
-Seething.
-[Slowly] Cinnamon bun.
-See-yah-low-bone-jaw?
-Cinnamon.
-Sipping!
-Bun.
-Bunny's.
-Cinnamon bun.
-Team buddy's.
-I keep getting
"sleeping bunnies."
[ Laughter ]
-Cinnamon bun is what it was.
-Oh, cinnamon bun!
Bun! Oh, my God.
-You got bun is close.
-Oh, wow.
-Judges, can we get
half a point on that.
[ Bell dings ]
Perfect. We got to have
a point on that.
-That's cheating.
-I know it is.
Alright.
Now I want to play. You --
Oh, and then I do it with you.
-Yeah.
And, dude, we're going to get
this. We're partners.
-Okay. Okay, okay.
-Oh, I know.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah. I know.
It's a really exciting song.
Okay. Alright.
Pink lemonade.
-Pela melena.
-Pink lemonade.
-Pel the mel.
-Pick the mix.
-Pink.
-Pale.
-Lemonade.
-The mail.
-Pink.
-Pal.
lemonade.
-Tha maow.
[ Laughter ]
-Pink lemonade.
-Pal the mal.
-Pink --
-Oh.
-Pink.
-Pale, p-pran.
-Puh, pyah, play? Play.
-Pink.
-Bay. Pain!
Pay? Pay it forward.
-Pin-kuh.
-Kuh? Pain kuh?
-Pink.
-Pain kuh?
-Pink!
-Paycheck?
-Pink.
-Pika. Pika.
-Achoo, God bless you.
-Lemonade.
-You're welcome.
-Wha?
-Lemonade.
-De bella.
-[ Slowly ] Lemonade.
-The balls.
[ Laughter ]
Sorry.
-Lemonade.
-The ba--
[ Laughter ]
Are you kidding me?
Can you do it?
-Pink lemonade.
-Pele, the soccer player.
I have no idea. What?
Pink lemonade.
What? It doesn't look
like that at all.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Sorry. Sorry.
That was my fault.
Alright.
-Okay.
Let's just scratch these two.
Pretend they didn't even.
-You were so close to saying
"pink" as well.
-I was not okay. Ready?
-Okay, here we go.
-Alright. We're gonna get there.
-Oh, gosh.
[ Laughter ]
N-F-T.
-Enough T?
-Yeah. That's it! Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was it. yes!
-That was it?
-Yes!
-I don't believe you.
-Oh, I said --
-Y-Y-Y-you said --
-I said "Enough T."
-Yeah, it worked.
The audience, no,
the audience liked it.
And everyone's getting enough
tea after the show.
That's perfect.
Enough T. That counts.
That counts. Buddy, we got
there. Here we go.
We have one more.
-Well, I love this game.
Where you really just, you know,
you can lose and win every time.
-Oh, okay. Here we go. Last one.
This one's worth 10,000 points.
Here we go.
Come on. We got this, buddy.
-Okay.
-Partners.
-Okay. Okay.
Velociraptor.
-Velociraptor?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Bryce Dallas Howard, everybody.
"Jurassic World: Dominion"
is in theaters and IMAX today.